[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIE VENDETTUOLI: Hi,
I'm Marie Vendettuoli.
I'm a senior statistical
programmer at Fred Hutch
and the Statistical Center
for HIV/AIDS Research
and Prevention.
At RStudio Conf 2020,
my colleague Ellis Hughes
shared technical
details demonstrating
how R organization is tackling
the challenge of software
validation for R packages.
It's now a year later.
We have three packages
released and are
tackling the extended
challenge of ensuring
that our entire verse is fit for
purpose as an integrated unit.
Today, I'll be
sharing my thoughts
regarding multi package
development in the pharma
environment.
My first recommendation
is to set the team up
for success by getting
infrastructure in order.
Moving away from historical
validation practices
needs updating or
generating new SOPs.
Another area for
infrastructure support
is to establish common
development guidelines that
get shared across all packages.
This is especially
important if packages
are implementing legacy code
that was previously siloed.
The ultimate benefit, however,
is code portability within
the overall project.
My next recommendation is the
need to address development
from an empathy perspective.
At Scharp, we observe
four distinct roles, one,
users rapidly processing data.
These would be primarily
statistical programmers.
Two, data analyst
reviewing code for context.
These would be
individuals who need
to be able to rapidly
assess context
from function names law.
Three, stakeholders interacting
with function solely
from the package
validation report.
So this could be
someone involved
in writing specifications
and test cases
but aren't participating
in coding activity.
Four, package developers
and maintainers
who seek to eliminate
duplication or re-implementation
with package updates.
Now one common need that transcends
all of these user groups
is to have a vocabulary, which
allows us to place functions
within the larger context of
assay specific data processing
tasks, that is, we want
to survey what has been
implemented, filter
either by assay or task,
and call up help page
documentation on demand.
So this is actually a reference
to Schneiderman's information
seeking mantra, which
is typically cited
in visualizations literature.
In this context, we are
treating the function names
as identifying
handle and leveraging
RStudio's autocomplete as
the filtering mechanism
as we navigate to a particular
help page or call the function.
For example, one step
of data processing
that occurs for all assays
is the transformation
to a cdisc ADaM
Basic Data Structure.
Because of the function naming
convention we have chosen,
a list of all available BDS
transformation functions
are displayed and we can select
for the assay of interest.
Focusing on the package
validation elements,
we also need a
systematic approach
to how we map package
requirements, test cases,
and test code files.
Validation as a form of user
acceptance testing, where
we have to show that for
every software requirement
there was an appropriate
test successfully executed.
The modular approach
we use at Scharp
is incredibly flexible,
which has the development
benefits I will discuss later.
But it does require some
organization to track.
In addition to enforcing
a file naming convention,
we also scrape these files
to generate a tabular display
in the validation report, which
links requirements and tests.
Between these two
implementations,
both developers and
validation report stakeholders
are able to verify at a glance
that complete coverage exists.
The last couple
of recommendations
I have addressed the
topic of technical debt.
You may be wondering, why
are we splitting assays
into separate packages?
A couple of reasons.
First, FTA guidance ask us to
revalidate the entire system
one element changes.
Now change is expected,
input data structures
get updated,
analysis needs drift.
However, an update
to one assay type
should not introduce
the appearance of change
affecting other assays.
Secondly, from the
user perspective,
we need to put some conceptual
structures around processes.
Sure, every data set
will be converted to BDS
but the definition of
that basic data structure
will vary from assay to assay.
We need to capture that
distinction in a manner that
is easy to digest.
What we also want to avoid is
excessive re-implementation.
As we have expanded to
multiple assay packages,
we have identified
utility functions
that could be shared and moved
into their own foundation
package.
We can enforce package
code dependencies
through routine use of
the description file.
With the power of
modular validation
means that we can move the
associated specifications,
test cases, and test
code files as well.
Validation of the lighter assay
package with the new utility
package is simply compiling
the R Markdown document
without any need
to rewrite content.
Likewise, when we need to add
additional specifications, test
cases, or test code to
an existing package,
an updated validation report
will add new child documents
to existing sources.
This has the added
benefit of being
able to use a simple dev to
compare validation reports
across package versions.
So I wanted to take
a moment to thank
those who made
this work possible,
especially the preceding
efforts by Ellis Hughes
and the combined contribution of
the Scharp Data Standardization
team.
Future work includes formalizing
our validation practice
through a fuse or
a collaboration
with deliverables
expected later in 2021.